-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden published
an op-ed today
in The New York Times
and that man is spiraling.
[ Laughter ]
Fox News host Tucker Carlson
last night claimed
that the security camera footage
from the Capitol attack
"does not show an insurrection
or a riot in progress."
Yeah, okay,
but when you cherry-pick
the footage you're showing,
you can prove whatever you want.
I could show you footage
from "John Wick"
that proves he's not violent.
Take a look.
-[ Whining ]
[ Laughter ]
-We'll grab you
some kibble later.
[ Tender tune plays ]
[ Collar rings against bowl ]
-You're telling me that guy
[ Laughter ]
is a trained killer?
Give me a break!
[ Laughter ]
The footage doesn't lie.
After Fox News
host Tucker Carlson
aired exclusive security footage
from the Capitol attack,
former President Trump posted
on Truth Social,
"LET THE JANUARY 6
PRISONERS GO."
You guys know we can see
what you're doing, right?
[ Laughter ]
Kevin McCarthy,
who is Trump's Waylon Smithers,
[ Laughter ]
gives all the footage
to Tucker;
Tucker shows
only the tame parts;
and then Trump claims
the rioters were framed.
It's like watching a magic show
where the magician
is wearing sheer sleeves.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They do have very nice sheer
sleeves on the magician.
[ Laughter ]
Didn't know how
it was going to look.
I find out with you guys.
It's the best way
to do quality control.
[ Laughter ]
In a new episode of her podcast,
former First Lady
Michelle Obama said
that she sobbed uncontrollably
for 30 minutes
after leaving the White House
at the end
of President Obama's term.
As opposed to her husband,
who dealt
with his post-presidency grief
more stoically.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Columbia University last week
announced they will no longer
require SAT or ACT scores
in undergraduate admissions,
while UMass announced
that you no longer need
that show-and-tell project.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Massachusetts' own
Mike Scollins.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Transportation Secretary
Pete Buttigieg
pushed back against critics
characterizing him
as being elitist
and out of touch
and said his critics,
"wouldn't know their way
around a T.J.Maxx
if their life depended on it."
[ Laughter ]
But if you're lost
inside a T.J.Maxx,
your life does depend on it.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Pete Buttigieg said,
"You think Tucker Carlson
knows the difference
between a T.J.Maxx
and a Kohl's?"
Actually, he might,
because aren't those his sons?
[ As Carlson ]
T.J.Maxx, Kohl!
[ Laughter ]
It's time for lacrosse practice.
Let's go!
[ Laughter ]
Grocery delivery service
Hello Fresh confirmed yesterday
it will stop selling
coconut milk from Thailand
over concerns
of forced monkey labor.
From now on, they're only going
to use union monkeys.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A group of entrepreneurs
in Massachusetts
have filed paperwork to open
a topless marijuana dispensary,
[ Oohs ]
though they might run
into some legal issues,
since they're ten.
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
"Hi, we'd like to file
some papers.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we have an idea
for a business.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, can we -- can we put here
'Don't tell our parents'?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in honor
of St. Patrick's Day,
Dairy Queen is offering its new
Under the Rainbow Shake,
which features
vanilla soft serve
and multicolored sprinkles.
And Arby's is honoring
St. Paddy's Day
by driving all the snakes
out of the kitchen.
[ Laughter ]
And that --
that was a monologue.
We're off and running,
everybody.
We got a great show
for you tonight.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
He is a dear,
dear friend of mine
with many credits --
"The Mindy Project,"
"Neighbors," "The Afterparty,"
but none of his credits make him
as happy as his new title
of Celebrity Jeopardy! Champion.
We'll talk about his
hilarious new show,
"History of the World, Part II,"
but probably not as much
as how he won all
of Celebrity Jeopardy!
The very funny Ike Barinholtz
is here tonight, everybody.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
She stars in "Scream VI,"
which is out this week.
We'll be joined by the very
talented actress
Melissa Barrera.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And she is the legendary author
of "The Handmaid's Tale"
and many others.
Her latest...
...is on sale now.
The great Margaret Atwood
is back and joining us.
[ Cheering and applause ]
How exciting.
Before we get to all that,
if you've been following
the news recently,
you may have seen that movie
theater chain AMC plans
to start charging higher prices
for better seats in the theater.
You know, hearing things
like that always,
well, it gets me to thinking
I'm getting older, you guys,
[ Laughter ]
and sometimes
I don't even understand
the world I'm living in anymore.
[ Southern accent ]
Things are changing every day,
and not always for the better.
[ Laughter ]
So, it's time to take a moment
to talk about how things were
just a little bit more simple
back in my day.
[ Poignant tune plays ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Back in my day, AMC wasn't
charging more for better seats.
Back in my day, if you wanted
good seats at the theater,
you could take your pick
because the year was 2021
and everyone else was afraid
to leave the house.
[ Laughter ]
And if, by some miracle,
there was someone else
in the theater that day
and they were sitting
where you wanted to sit,
all you had to do was plop down
in the seat right next to them
and give a little cough.
[ Laughter ]
Right within striking distance
of their popcorn.
Just a little one, like this.
[ Coughs ]
Pretty soon,
the whole place was yours.
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day,
they weren't selling
Hard Mountain Dew.
Sugarfoot!
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day,
if you wanted
a hard Mountain Dew,
you bought a regular
two-liter Mountain Dew bottle,
poured half out, and filled
the rest up with Everclear.
[ Laughter ]
It was the only alcohol you had
to be 21 and under to drink.
[ Laughter ]
Let's just say, after a couple
of hard Mountain Dews,
if you made it back to the
bedroom with your best gal,
there would be no Baja Blast.
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day,
we weren't banning TikTok.
if you wanted to get people
to stop using
a social media platform,
why, you'd just get Elon Musk
to buy it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Back in my day,
politicians weren't trying
to ban drag shows.
If you didn't want to see men
in stockings and wigs
and makeup,
well, then you just stayed
the hell away
from the Founding Fathers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
With their big --
[ Cheering ]
They had big old feathers
on their pens.
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
Back in my day, newspapers
weren't dropping "Dilbert"
because its creator went
on a racist rant.
Back in my day,
the comics place was an escape,
an innocent place where nothing
controversial ever happened.
Well, except for that one time
Linus went hard in the paint
and claimed there were
micro magnets in the vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
But, hey, he was right
about the Great Pumpkin.
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day,
we weren't watching
"The Last of Us" on HBO.
Cable sauce!
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day,
if we were watching HBO,
it was a little show called
"Real Sex."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, the sex was weird
and everybody was ugly,
but before the Internet,
that was your best option,
if you wanted to see a boob.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You think the "Last of Us" folks
have it bad,
try cranking it to a group
of 80-year-olds learning
to have a 30-day orgasm.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Come to think about it,
I think that episode
was called "The Blast of Us."
[ Laughter ]
I feel like you're purposely
not making eye contact with me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Back in my day,
California wasn't being hit
with 6.5 feet of snow.
If you wanted to see 6.5 feet
of white powder in California,
you had to visit Charlie Sheen
on the set
of "Two and a Half Men."
[ Cheering ]
-[ Barks ]
-Yeah, that's right.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, I'm winning.
Back in my day, trains full
of toxic chemicals
weren't constantly derailing
in Ohio.
Back in my day,
if you wanted to see something
go off the rails
and cause a toxic environment,
you had to visit Charlie Sheen
on the set
of "Two and a Half Men."
-[ Barks ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Diminishing returns, you say?
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day,
1,000 British people
weren't breaking
the Guinness World Record
for most people
crocheting simultaneously.
No, If you want to see
that many hookers,
you had to visit Charlie Sheen
[ Mumbling ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Growling ]
-Alright, alright.
[ Cheering ]
I'll let it go.
Relax!
[ Laughter ]
It's called the rule of threes.
Twenty-one, for you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Back in my day,
guests at art fairs
weren't breaking Jeff Koons'
balloon animal statues.
Van Gogh [bleep] yourself!
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day, if you wanted
to destroy a balloon,
you had to get
a U.S. fighter jet
to fire a heat-seeking missile
at it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Why, I still remember
those days,
way back in February 2023.
[ Laughter ]
You felt proud
to be an American,
shooting those balloons
out of the sky.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Even though, even now,
you don't really understand
what was going on.
First, there was just
the one balloon,
then there were like six,
then maybe it turned out some
of those weren't real.
There were like multiple
press conferences, I think.
In any case, it's over now.
Or it's not.
[ Laughter and applause ]
For as much as we talked
about it,
I feel like I should know
a few more details.
[ Laughter ]
News just move so fast,
these days, Rusty.
[ Laughter ]
Look. at. me!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Back in my day,
streaming services
weren't pulling all their shows.
NBC was.
[ Laughter ]
Did you know we once had a show
on this network
called "Animal Practice"
and it starred an actual monkey?
[ Laughter ]
I think it was canceled
mid-episode.
Meanwhile, I tried to get
an actual dog on this show,
aka the easiest animal
to get on Earth...
[ Laughter ]
...and the brass was like,
"How about a stuffed dog
that's made of a material
you're definitely allergic to?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Barks ]
-No, oh, no.
This was a --
a different thing, Rusty.
You're a real dog.
[ Laughter ]
Back in my day,
Bing didn't have a chat box.
Well, who knows?
Maybe they did.
No one ever used it to find out.
[ Laughter ]
All I know is that, back then,
if you said the words
chatbot by Bing,
somebody in a bar might respond
with a bing bop howdy bow
[ Laughter ]
and then you'd reply with a
chitty chitty bebop shoo bop bow
and then they'd hit you back
with a
skiddly doo skiddly doo
skiddly doo dop wham
and then the bartender, he'd
chase you both out with a broom,
shouting, "I told you
freaky jazz nuts,
there's no scat singing
in this here establishment.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Go bing your chatty ding dong
somewhere else!"
[ Laughter ]
Simpler times.
Well,
I apologize
that I had to do that,
but sometimes
this grumpy old Gus has to...
oh, yeah,
you know what I'm drinking.
[ Laughter and applause ]
...get his gripe on.
This has been "Back in My Day."